[Musique]
on nous raconte maintenant la troublante
histoire de nadège nadège c'est une
jeune rwandaise avait de super bonnes
notes décroché une bourse pour venir
étudier ici au québec
mais juste avant de partir elle comprend
que la vraie mission que lui a réservé
son gouvernement
ce sera d'espionner ici l'espionnage
on la sait si souvent à de grandes
puissances comme la russie ou la chine
pas un pays comme le rwanda vingt-cinq
ans après un génocide qui a fait 800
mille morts ce pays a cité comme un
modèle de résilience et de développement
et son leader paul kagame comme le
visionnaire responsable de cette
réussite
mais derrière l'image brillante se
cacherait un régime autoritaire qui ne
tolérait aucune dissidence et le
gouvernement font des affranchis mis en
place en en ciblant nos enfants il ya
débat continue comme ça cette grosse
tête on doit la faire exploser
un gouvernement
qui surveille et trax écrite et à
l'étranger même jusqu ici au canada
on a dit il est un homme au canada tu
dois trop
[Musique]
bureau de l'agencé canadienne des
services frontaliers à montréal un agent
est déroge une rwandaise qui veut
obtenir l'asile politique au canada
ce qui suit est une reconstitution des
faits à partir des transcriptions de
cette audience
je suis chiante acajun d'exécution de la
loi pour l'unité sécurité et crimes de
guerre
c'est une demande d'asile particulière
la rwandaise que nous appellerons nadège
affirme être une espionne --l'agence
enquête sur quel moment pour vous aider
à partir le même respect des personnes
et ont vu de tels renseignements en 2010
je devais signer un homme dans le but de
chercher de l'information sur ses
parents on m'avait dit qu'il travaille
avec des gens qui font du terroriste
pour mandat toutes ces personnes là qui
se sont enfuis à l'extérieur du pays ce
sont des ennemis que donc on doit aller
chercher et il comprend
[Musique]
le dossier de nadège a piqué notre
curiosité et en fouillant on a découvert
que des espions rwandais ont déjà été
sur le radar au canada on sait depuis
2014 que des agents rouen des arts celle
des réfugiés ainsi des cas d'espionnage
rwandais sont aussi rapportés en suède
en australie et en belgique
les membres des services de
renseignement ne se livre pas facilement
je ne peux rien dire et je ne dirai rien
[Musique]
au canada nous n'avons trouvé personne
pour commenter ce dossier mais en
belgique
guy rapaille a longtemps dirigé le
comité qui surveille les services de
renseignement de son pays
les rondeurs ont la réputation d'être
actif et efficace en ayant acquis toutes
les ficelles du métier de la jante
renseignement ce sont de vrais
professionnels des professionnels dit il
possiblement dangereux en 2017 et 2018
j'ai été informé de l'arrivée en europe
de membres de services de renseignement
rwandais qui étaient chargés d'éliminer
des opposants ou du moins de faire des
pressions sur des opposants potentiels
pour les obliger à se montrer discret et
ce ne sont pas seulement les recoins des
kiss
visés je marchais vers mon hôtel au
coeur de la ville de poxel je suis à
l'erea la réception est tout de suite un
monsieur est venu vers moi et m'a dit où
cette gt oui en 2014
djoudi weaver se trouve justement en
belgique lorsqu'il est abordé par un
représentant de la sûreté de l'état
il lui dit que sa sécurité un
sérieusement menacé la montréalaise est
une journaliste et auteure indépendante
l enquête depuis plus de vingt ans sur
les événements entourant le génocide au
rwanda
j'étais bouleversé j'étais pourquoi et
il m'a dit qu il avait là les
informations crédibles que l'ambassade
rwandaise en belgique constituait un une
menace contre m'habille deux gardes du
corps en voiture blindée pour la suivre
jour et nuit durant son séjour d'une
semaine en belgique pour la première
fois dans ma vie et je me suis dit c'est
très curieux c'est très dangereux et le
régime est prête à faire tout ce qu'ils
peuvent pour m'empêcher de travailler
à l'époque du vieux prépare un livre
pour remettre en question la version
officielle du drame rwandais une version
trop simple selon elle de bons et de
méchants sont en quête s'annonce
dévastatrice pour le gouvernement kagame
l'histoire du génocide une histoire
officielle et ceux ci les routes où sont
des bourreaux sont les méchants et les
victimes sont les tout petits le 6 avril
le président rwandais habyarimana un
hutu est tué dans un attentat d'avion
c'est l'étincelle qui déclenché une
frénésie de violence contre la minorité
tutsi
le génocide ne prend fin que lorsque les
rebelles tutsi du fpr
front patriotique rwandais dirigé par
paul kagamé envahi ce pays
il y avait des informations durant le
génocide des rapports qui indiquait aux
nations unies à l'époque que les troupes
de kagamé tuer en masse des réfugiés des
déplacés foot ou dans l'est du rwanda
dans son livre la journaliste reconnaît
le génocide contre les tutsis mais son
ouvrage est très controversé parce
qu'elles affirment que les troupes de
paul kagame ont tous situés au moins 500
milles rwandais pendant et après le
génocide
surtout des hutus des chiffres
impossibles à confirmer
il y avait toute une partie de
l'histoire qu'on n'avait pas entendu et
que le gouvernement dehors de cas gamin
voulait pas un soit révélée la
journaliste a mis la main sur un rapport
d'enquêteurs secret de 2003 qui émane du
tribunal international créée après le
génocide
le document énumère une liste de tueries
commises en 1994 par les troupes de paul
kagamé perpétré même sur des femmes et
des enfants
mais ces informations étaient enterrés
nadège la jeune espionne rwandaise a
accepté de nous accorder une entrevue
pour nous raconter son histoire
mais elle craint pour sa sécurité nous
avons donc décidé de cacher son identité
et de changer certains détails de son
récit je faisais mes études
universitaires à kigali
on nous a appris qu'il y avait des
bourse pour aller étudier à l'étranger
on m'a dit que j'avais eu la bourse de
la francophonie et que je devais aller
au canada
nadège dit qu'elle croyait que la bourse
était une récompense pour son excellence
scolaire et pour son travail de cadre au
sein du fpr le parti de paul kagamé
j'ai donc commencé à faire les
formations tout se passait bien jusqu'à
la dernière rencontre qu'on a lui qui
était au camp militaire de la crau c'est
là que que j'ai appris que je devais
faire ce ce travail d'espionner
quelqu'un elle affirme que des
militaires donner cette formation à
laquelle assistait une trentaine de
personnes la formation consistait
justement comment trouver des
informations
comment approcher les gens comment se
comporter quelles sont les armes à avoir
c'était comme des mises en situation est
ce que il y avait beaucoup d'autres
étudiants comme ceux qui partaient à
l'étranger avec des missions pour
espionner je ne sais pas on ne pouvait
pas le savoir ce qu'on répétait à chaque
fois tu dois être quelqu'un de discret
de secret personne ne savait à part moi
même pas mon mari
[Musique]
commencer à changer la routine parce
qu'on avait peur d'être suivi et surtout
c'était angoissant pour mes enfants
parce qu'il fallait les surveiller
pourtant avant la publication de son
livre choc
judy wheeler affirme qu'elle avait
souvent été suivies mais un incident à
montréal en 2013
la particulièrement ébranlées je suis
sorti avec ma famille pour un souper
après un concert mais le lendemain j'ai
vu qu'ils avaient un message sur le
répondeur
j'entendais la voix d'une femme
africaine
le message est étrange mais il contient
des codes menaçant pour judy elle
faisait la simulation des explosions et
des tirs et
j'étais effrayé et elle a mentionné le
nom de ma fille
qui avait 6 ans à l'époque à langer
j'avais très peur et j'ai donné cet
enregistrement à à la police et mon mari
va dit que les rwandais le gouvernement
rendait à franchir en nous menaçant en
ciblant nos enfants de retour au bureau
de l'agencé des services frontaliers à
montréal donc vous comment vous avez
fait votre travail
nadège était interrogé sur les moyens
qu'elle prenait pour remplir sa mission
d'espionnage
- arrivé ici j'allais dans les réunions
de la communauté rwandaise dans l'est
fait combien de fait et vous 5,6 et donc
c'est de l'art c'est fait la queue vous
poser des questions pour trouver les
parents oui à l'agent des services
frontaliers
elle raconte avoir suivi le jeune homme
est même réussi à lui parler au cours
d'une défaite rwandaise
mais sans grand succès il se méfie
pourquoi il se méfie autant parce qu'ils
se disent que ce sont des espions que
ces gens qui arrivent ici ils sont
envoyés par le gouvernement rwandais qui
leur veut du mal est ce que vous aviez
des contacts avec quelqu'un au canada
sur votre mission oui j'étais en contact
avec un représentant du haut
commissariat à ottawa parce que c'est
lui qui était chargé de recueillir les
informations vous alliez voir à ottawa
ou non c'est lui qui venait me voir
finalement nadège réussi à découvrir
dans quel pays se trouve le couple
recherché par le gouvernement rwandais
mais elle assure qu'elle n'a jamais
transmis l'information aux représentants
du haut commissariat
elle a eu vent d'une tentative
d'assassinât contre nous posant à
l'étranger et le doute s'installe c'est
là où j'ai pris conscience que c'est
pour ça si pour les tuer qu'on cherche
les gens qui sont à l'extérieur du
rwanda et j'ai commencé à me demander
mais qu'est ce que je fais
si je continue ils vont être tués à
cause de moi dans un instant des
opposants traquer et tuer à l'étranger
[Musique]
dès les premières années du gouvernement
qu'il y avait des exilés rwandais aurait
été ciblé parce qu'il en savait trop sur
le régime
cette semaine à shanghai sera l'un des
cas les plus célèbres en 1996 cet ancien
ministre rwandais et réfugiés au kenya
lorsqu'il est contacté par des
connaissances elle affirme vouloir lui
remettre des documents importants
enfin il a eu cet appel et partir et
voir est arrivé là sur place et s'est
rendu compte très vite qu'il est tombé
dans un piège
je suis rentré dans ma voiture j'ai
ouvert la fenêtre et je commençais à
faire fonctionner le moteur que j'ai vu
le jeune homme sortir en pistolet et mot
tiré à bout portant et la balle qui
était destiné à ma tête m'a finalement
touché que mon épaule ici un homme est
arrêté dans la toilette d'une
station-service pistolet silencieux et
presse cartouches à la main un membre de
l'ambassade rwandaise au kenya c'était
vraiment une situation très très grave
diplomate qui a impliqué dans une
tentative d'assassinât dans un pays
étranger
le diplomate ne fera jamais face à la
justice puisque le rwanda refuse de
lever son immunité diplomatique
cette semaine à shanghai un défenseur
des droits de la personne où tout
s'était joint au groupe de rebelles de
paul kagame dans les années 90 plein
d'espoir lorsque le parti de kagame
arrivé au pouvoir après le génocide 7
est nommé ministre de l'intérieur la
photo là ça sautait son portrait quand
il était ministre
sa photo a fait la photo officielle sa
femme syrie est une citoyenne canadienne
qui a longtemps vécu à montréal
siri raconte qu'à l'époque son mari
déchante rapidement il reçoit un nombre
croissant de rapports sur des crimes
commis dans les mois qui ont suivi le
génocide par l'armée de son gouvernement
cela on sent qu'ils obéissent à des
ordres bien clair et bien ciblée de
d'éliminer la population
c'était avant une politique délibérée
d'assassiner la population surtout la
population auto il accumule les preuves
contre les régimes il devient de plus en
plus dérangeant parce que les gens qui
savent que je sais ce que je sais et
continueront à avoir peur de moi je suis
prêt à ce que tous les sacrifices et
soient consentis pour cette noble cause
cette dernière phrase va se révéler
prémonitoire le 16 mai 1998
cette semaine à shanghai sera l'objet
d'une deuxième attaque
et cette fois il n'y survivra pas vous
vivez avec cette possibilité mais en se
disant toujours on espère que ça va pas
se passer mais l'idée peut il allait
être comme ça assassiné en plein jour en
plein en pleine rue c'était impensable
après une enquête bâclée au kenya trois
hommes sont accusés puis acquitté donc
je pense que son assassinat a été
vraiment une onde de choc
il n'hésite pas de de têtu et leur
proposons des heurts dans le pays
c'est quelque chose qui ont augmenté et
et puis les années 90
et ça continue jusqu'à maintenant luis
mode et son organisation ont dû quitté
le rwanda en raison de leurs critiques
du gouvernement rwandais
human rights watch enquêter sur de
nombreux cas de menaces de tortures de
disparitions et d'assassinats aux pandas
mais aussi à l'étranger au kenya en
ouganda en afrique du sud et même en
grande bretagne et malheureusement il y
à d'autres cas où on soupçonne on a
vraiment les indices disons que les
tares ont délié mais on n'a pas de
preuves et on peut pas trop on peut pas
prendre possession
en 2014 les journalistes canadiens judy
wheeler et jefferies york ont obtenu ce
qui s'approche le plus d'une preuve de
l'implication de l'état arguant des
temps des complots d'assassinats
d'opposants à l'étranger il s'agit
simplement de te procurer des armes et
de faire le travail nous sommes en 2011
il s'agit d'une conversation entre deux
militaires
le directeur du renseignement de
l'époque tente de convaincre un ancien
officier d'éliminer deux opposants
réfugiés en afrique du sud
l'officier fait semblant de collaborer
et enregistre en secret les
conversations la méthode n'a pas
vraiment d'importance
ce qui importe c'est de compléter le
travail ils sont clairement les
terroristes
le rwanda était prête à payer un million
de dollars pour tuer les 6 il discute
comment approcher comme embaucher les
garde-corps de ces monsieurs infiltrer
le milieu et on en trouvait des armes et
les munitions
mais ce que je te dis ceux qui ont fait
ça ont été bien traitées financièrement
[Musique]
deux ans plus tard l'une des deux cibles
est retrouvée étranglée dans sa chambre
d'hôtel de johannesburg l'ancien
officier donne les enregistrements aux
journalistes
notons qu'hier mouture loi votée en
réaction à cet assassinat
le président paul kagame tient ces
propos troublants cris falls à monaco
lycées des izards au québec
nadège est ébranlée par ses attaques
contre des opposants elle est maintenant
convaincu dit elle qu'elle ne doit pas
complété sa mission
c'est là que j'ai commencé à avoir ni
comme les regrets je veux dire c'est là
où vous vous êtes dit je veux pas
transmettre cette information
elle affirme que le représentant du haut
commissariat s'impatiente devant son peu
de progrès si là qu'il m'a dit il faut
avoir des informations coûte que coûte
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pour pour
mettre fin à votre mission vous éloignez
j'ai coupé tout contact avec lui nous
avons tenté à plusieurs reprises de
corroborer les affirmations de nadège
auprès du haut-commissariat du rwanda à
ottawa sans succès selon son avocate
le canada devrait accorder l'asile
politique à nadège même si elle a commis
un acte d'espionnage elle n'a pas
terminé sa mission
elle n'a pas révélé l'intégralité des
informations sensibles qu'elle a pu
recueillir donc n'y a pas de vie qui ont
été mis en danger
si le gouvernement canadien il doit
donner l'exemple de encourager les gens
qui ont été envoyés comme ça sous la
contrainte pour espionner à l'étranger
il doit permettre à ces gens là d'avoir
une porte de sortie en octobre 2014
la décision du tribunal de l'immigration
tombe
la demande est rejetée le commissaire
conclut que nadège a effectué de
l'espionnage
et que cet acte d'espionnage contrevient
aux valeurs de tout état démocratique et
donc contraires aux intérêts du canada
selon le commissaire nadège a accepté
volontairement d'espionner en échange
d'une bourse d'étude la rwandaise devra
et expulsé du territoire canadien
à moins d'un ultime recours le pire dans
tout ça c'est que le canada le sait mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait est exactement la
suite de notre enquête
après la pause les déconnectent ils sont
au courant que le torture existe mais ce
n'est pas tellement prioritié autonome
[Musique]
dealbook ème place à la mangue
c'était ma favorite tout montréal venait
chercher la glace et ses vingt ans plus
tard série nicosie cndd à shanghaï
cherche toujours les assassins de son
mari pour moi c'est absolument un
important que on identifier comment
pourquoi et par qui il a été tué je
pense que pour moi pour mes enfants pour
ma famille et même pour la société
hollandaise de manière générale un cri
où il faut qu'on identifie les auteurs
et que justice soit faite
en fait qui pensez vous le tuez vous
êtes persuadé que c'est le gouvernement
bah oui ce tournoi il ya plus de doute
depuis quelques semaines kagame lui même
l'a révélé à la face du monde entier
[Musique]
bien mba me semble d'accord c'est
celle-là chang en mars dernier paul
kagame est soudainement revenu sur le
meurtre du mari de syrie il a fait une
déclaration surprenante décor
faute d'oxygène aux jambes a dû crossed
the lines a écrit mme gaubert m le
desserrement du matériel sono
apologétique bâti pour série c'est un
aveu pour nous les rouennais qui savons
plus ou moins comment est ce la façon de
s'exprimer de kagamé où il n'y a pas
l'ombre d'un doute que en fait il est en
train de dire voilà je sais moi l'auteur
ou deux c'est moi qui ai donné les
ordres et je ne regrette pas la mort de
sept cents à shanghai le président
kagame ni qu'il s'agisse d'une
reconnaissance de sa culpabilité mais
syrie ils voient un message clair c'est
une façon donc de continuer à semer la
terreur dans l'opposition qui hélas
l'extérieur du pays et les autres
leaders du rwanda de dire faites
attention s'il faut tuer je vais pas
hésiter pas
5 juillet dernier au château laurier à
ottawa
le haut-commissariat du rwanda organise
une soirée pour le 25e anniversaire du
jour de la libération qui marque la fin
du génocide
[Musique]
le représentant du gouvernement canadien
n'a que de bons mots aussi sur
l'évolution du pays depuis 25 ans
organisée
nous dûmes est on
à l'étranger le rwanda est souvent
présentée comme une sorte de singapour
africaine où règnent ordre et propreté
on souligne ses progrès en matière
d'écologie et d'égalité entre hommes et
femmes mais siri la veuve de 700 à
shangha voudrais que la communauté
internationale s'intéresse aussi au côté
plus sombre du régime mais à les
regarder côté droit la situation des
droits de l'homme d'accepter que
l'opposition puisse s'exprimer librement
la liberté de la presse
non ça personne ne veux pas trop entrer
là-dedans quoi des pays comme le canada
à mon avis tous les pays peuvent faire
quelque chose sur tous les pays qui
entretiennent des relations avec le
rwanda qui l'aident en termes d'aidé au
développement il pourrait quand même
demander des comptes
le rwanda reçoit environ un milliard de
dollars par année en aide internationale
le canada lui a versé plus de 650
millions $ depuis 1994
mais ottawa se montre plutôt discret
lorsque vient le temps d'aborder la
question des droits humains au rwanda
c'est un régime qui n'a pas beaucoup de
tolérance justement face à la face à la
critique
marie-eve desrosiers de l'université
d'ottawa étudie le rwanda depuis plus de
15 ans j'ai plutôt l'impression que le
canada adopte la position de le faire
lorsque possible de soulever la question
lorsque possible mais pas de façon
directe et confrontations l écoute des
choses marchent
ça va il n'y a pas il n'y a pas une girl
who is not a human rights watch crois
que les pays donateurs ne vois pas trop
l'intérêt de confronter le régime
les diplomates ils sont au courant que
le torture existe et son tocoron que les
gens qui sont portées disparues restent
appartement premier tour de fait les
propres rapports internes d'affaires
mondial canada dresse une longue liste
de problèmes journaliste museler
disparitions d'opposants détentions
illégales et torture
il est clair que le régime se durcit
selon marie-eve desrosiers j'aurais
tendance à losers justement un des gros
problèmes de cette tendance à avancer de
manière à intéresser très diplomatique
je pense aller c'est beaucoup beaucoup d
face au régime pour s'affirmer et
prendrait tendance de plus en plus
autoritaire au fil du temps la posture
canadienne et devrait être possible
effectivement plus ferme aujourd'hui
pour le spécialiste en aide humanitaire
françois audet le canada devrait revoir
son approche face au rwanda d'avoir été
solidaires suite au génocide c'était
évidemment fondamental de pouvoir de
laisser à la population rwandaise toute
la chance et l'opportunité de se
reconstruire
mais bon le temps passer et je crois
qu'on ne peut plus laisser l'espace à un
président aussi autoritaire
nadège est persuadé que sa sécurité
serait menacé si elle devait retourner
au rwanda
malgré l'avis d'expulsion qui pèsent
contre elle et lui reste une dernière
chance pour obtenir l'asile ici
convaincre les autorités que les risques
qu'elles courent au rwanda sont plus
grands que la menace qu'elle représente
pour le canada je pourrais être
maltraités ou tués si je retournais au
rwanda parce que oui on ne remplissant
pas ma mission d'espionnage j'ai trahi
le gouvernement rwandais
[Musique]
elle risque la torture le risque d'être
tué je pense pas que le sens de cette
dame devrait être
sur les mains du gouvernement canadien
[Musique]
c'est nadège elle même qui a divulgué
avoir fait de l'espionnage
elle se demande maintenant si c'était la
bonne décision - j'espérais que le
gouvernement canadien protège des gens
comme moi qui se sont retrouvés dans des
situations comme la mienne
j'aimerais être en paix ici au canada
ça fait environ cinq ans que j'attends
la réponse des autorités et mon espoir
commence à se perdre
[Musique]
on espère que vous avez apprécié nos
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
revenez nous la semaine prochaine pour
une autre enquête
non
[Musique]
je